nyc the big apple new york city ever
heard of it gang the boys are gonna be
here gotham comedy club november 9th on
the isle of manhattan we're coming back
we're storming the beaches get some
tickets and come see us it's the new
york comedy festival our first time in
it you don't want to miss it the show's
going to sell out also the boys are
going to be in hartford connecticut on
december 14th and we're going to go to
albany new york on december 15th and
then where are we going after that big
man we're gonna be in syracuse december
16th get those tickets
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage
the show where you find out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r.u garbage sure is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out they grew up
to be classy or just a big old piece of
trash you know it i'm your host holy
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at auntie's basement she's a
little anxious why well she knows that
our very special guest that's here with
this good friend of ours is canadian
all right she wants to see some papers
or something she's worried that we're
going to become canadian
she thinks you can catch it yeah i told
her it's not how it works they're good
people you don't say yeah so she said
let me know when he's gone choke them
out of bed
okay
she comes out in a mask
[Laughter]
space suit on praying lights all at him
i don't want to get in that canadian on
me my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he's the ceo of ru
garbage he's international businessman
he turns heads and board rooms all
across this great nation give it up for
kj
kevin james ryan hey gang happy to be
here thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true
cooking um
and then i'm contractually obligated by
the yam family and the jack conte family
to mention the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.comgarbridge you can sign up
get a bunch of content uh different
podcasts videos live streams the whole
nine yards get it it's all on there get
on it we love them thank you and have a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man he's our
own little yam family right here yeah
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up
dudes hey t-bone we got a canuck in the
house hockey fights let's go
pull the sweater over and get him
i feel like five for fighting i don't
know about you guys
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest back with us
again today it has been a while he was
one of our original guests second
episode second episode we're talking pre
pandemic pre-panty he's
[Laughter]
we're all garbage i mean look at this
we're in the back of a [ __ ] dog
gang he is one of our oldest friends on
the new york comedy scene one of our
best pals he is a very funny absolute
murderer murderer stand up comedian and
actor he's been on a late show with
stephen colbert been on tonight's show
stand up with john dore he's been on
conan and he's got a brand new show that
he's the star and creator that's coming
out we couldn't be more excited to have
him ladies and gentlemen mr nathan
mcintosh yeah guys thanks for having me
this is a great day
every time somebody asked me about you
guys i say these are some of the
greatest people that i know both of them
foley kip alone my name's my middle name
is also james and also i just met you're
a hero buddy you're a good man
thank you this guy's got great energy
wait till it turns sour then it's not so
good he turns quick and you're like just
no that is not true i'll stop picking
this up it says first time wearing
headphones
look i don't want to put the he doesn't
yo again look before we look like a baby
in a nascar race
i will say yet again you look like a
muppet dj
i will say one more time these [ __ ]
headphones are from the 80s don't come
at me with the two what do you what do
you want yourself these are from 2012
these these look like [ __ ] michael
keaton would have wore them in batman
like we're broadcasting
like wait what was michael
what's what's what's the joker doing
today he puts these on and listens to
the city just on a big sonar machine you
do look like you're in a sub right now
oh man in the radar you have it you have
a green light on your face well this is
a basement right i mean
yeah it's your why aunt dude yeah
[Laughter]
say whatever you want to say everybody
and people at home i appreciate you guys
for having me yeah i don't know what it
is
let's go man i pay tax i'm sorry go
ahead let's go back would i can't
remember if you were garbage or not but
you're definitely not garbage now
you very you you like to take care of
yourself you're always very well dressed
hair always looks good when did we do
this before 1995 how long ago was that
we're saying you grew up i think if i
remember a single mom oh that's what you
mean i thought you meant for the last
time i was on the podcast really gotten
this [ __ ] together in the last year
you're eating better
no yes yes
did i grow up as garbage 100 you grew up
kind of garbage but i remember your mom
your mom went above and beyond to make
things better i feel like her situation
if i remember
i remember she was trying to keep it
together she was trying to keep it
together yeah the best she can my dad
was out there he drove a trans am all
the way to alberta to punch the [ __ ]
ground for oil as you do when you're
from out where i'm from nova scotia i
said this before yeah oh yeah yeah you
drive out there blast metallica i mean
this was the 80s you know what i mean
wide open yeah blair and metallica enter
sandman as you [ __ ] speed across
canada to just punch the ground for oil
and my mom uh yeah me and my brother my
mom were out there what does that mean
punch the ground for oil looking for oil
thank you yeah is that what your dad
went and did that's what everybody from
where i'm from uh not everybody but a
lot of people from the maritimes go out
west the hell's america the maritimes is
a a collection of provinces that uh we
they're provinces
this guy's from narnia what are you
talking dude live from middle earth
i'm from where king kong goes to get
that sword to fight godzilla
if you look hard enough in that scene
you can see my mother in the background
screaming at my dad on the phone come
home you're red-headed one's annoying
they're in their 30s now wait did your
dad hit oil do you know
it
[Laughter]
sure on the oil rigs people people from
where i'm from a lot of people from
where i'm from go out to
alberta to work on the old rigs you make
a couple bucks you buy a few trucks you
[ __ ]
get some leather jackets this one i know
about people that people buy cocaine
hookers trucks two weeks on two weeks i
don't know you were an oil man
i don't sound too bad i'll tell you that
was your dad did he strike oil
just picture him out there with like a
dewalt drill just like a pickaxe
there will be blood yeah that's what i
thought you meant like he went like he
left to go that's where the workers
trying to find his own problems this is
the 21st century i mean you know what i
mean the good god canada's not that
[ __ ] far behind
yeah it's not the dark ages
uh but yeah so yeah so uh yeah i'm a
single parent right growing up yeah yeah
i remember uh
what what kind of car did she have there
was something i remember my mom she had
a couple of them she did she drove my uh
like a trans am for a minute she had a
lady and a trans am yeah with the
[ __ ] fire on it but that was when my
my dad was still kind of a
was he around i don't know what i drove
a trans with kids his training that's
not planning for the future that's great
there's no back seat in there
dude the two kids in the front seat no
my brother one time was in the was in
the the best break and the he's sitting
in the ass straight my brother was in
the back
is there a back to a trans there's like
a little as you just said there's like a
little uh these headphones are gonna
look say whatever you want
the he was sitting in the back the
little it's a little like oh yeah the
seat came forward remember that i never
got back there i don't remember i was in
the front a little bit and then we
didn't have this car for long also kids
in the front back in the 90s wide open
no seatbelts dude no see i remember like
if you got in your buddy's car and you
had to put your seatbelt on like [ __ ]
dorks what am i doing i'm gonna have to
just do this i hate it i hate it all i
hate these headphones so much i'm so
happy that i can hear myself well who
what what what podcast do you go to
where they have [ __ ] blue air i never
listen i never use headphones in any
podcast every single podcast i go do i
have to wear these and i go no why would
you and i go thank you this is the only
one where you guys are like look man
there's a goddamn we're in a basement
you can't let me just come in here and
do whatever i want i appreciate it
my brother want now this story doesn't
even matter anymore trans am and then
she also had remember that [ __ ] uh i
think it's a dodge celebrity
no celebrity ever drove one i don't even
know what that is
it's james woods sponsored it for a
little while that's 100 false no
it's like a it looked like uh uh
oldsmobile but it i think it was like a
little bit less shine it was a little it
was boxy too if i remember it was boxier
back in the the heyday of like boxy
sedans yeah there's a question for you
that i'd be curious you mentioned james
woods now we know that sometimes
american actors and celebrities they'll
go overseas and endorse products that
they don't endorse here do you remember
having anything like that when you were
in canada like was like johnny depp like
doing like orange juice commercials or
anything like that up there oh man let
me go back and think i think uh there
was i think brad pitt did a whole run of
uh maple syrup ads are you [ __ ]
kidding me yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
called aunt jemima and louise
[Laughter]
two three hour run of these maple syrup
no yeah
it's not like a japanese energy drink
also i love canada's either in the 1800s
or the far east
we're so close to this place that dude
no everything that we just about
everything we get is from here there'd
be some canadian people who would do
things but you guys wouldn't
get it at all how old were you when you
came here for the first time when you
visited oh my god 20
first time in your 20s yeah 22
[Music]
22. how old were you
is that the first time you traveled
internationally yeah well you left you
left nova scotia you left the country
for the first time to come to the us at
22. where'd you go niagara falls
yeah but on the canadian side i'm gonna
[ __ ] no where'd you come when you
came here for in 20 new york
right over here in this basement there
was uh no me and uh uh uh uh the guy
whatever i was in this competition at
the time okay dance um
arm wrestling what are we talking about
over the top another another that was
another uh ad stallone did this whole
thing with uh beavers
he arm wrestled a beaver and the whole
thing was like hey the beavers are
people too or whatever you resolve evil
you wouldn't take us in my movie
they they're not a bad stallone it
actually was i wasn't expecting you know
what i gotta be honest it wasn't that
bad thank you from nowhere have you
worked on this
no but you're also from philly so i feel
that everybody from philly knows a
little bit like you know what i mean
you're also of of you you remember the
you went to see rock movies in theaters
i did i saw rocky movies in theaters
yeah so rocky iv i saw in a theater it's
coming back i know it's an extended cut
director's cut yeah we're gonna go see
it
i've talked about this i've met him
before
yeah why i never told you this i didn't
know you were famous
[Laughter]
international business kidding me uh
there was um
it was what was the one that came out i
guess five it was five what was the one
where there was the huge his like the
re-r the
comeback rocky ball no balboa no rocky
balboa balboa then what was the next one
what was that's the last so yeah it was
rocky balboa yeah so it was balboa yeah
what was five tommy yeah guns yeah
it was balboa um and it was in philly
and he did this big premiere and i
somehow got tickets to like my aunt or
something and we went it was like this
vip tent
and there was like a ring and you could
stand in the ring and get your picture
taken with him like you both like stand
like this or whatever wow dude he's
about he goes all out he's about five
two not exaggerating like he's like the
tiny shortest man but front to back dude
chest to back like three feet wide all
hgh this dude is just sweating out
hormones i was gonna say an
o6 when he did uh
uh balboa 06 yeah but he i think he got
charged he got knocked in australia or
something that's what it was yeah he was
trying to fly back with a bag full of
hgh no shirts
no t-shirts no pants nothing just bags
of drawers
that sunglasses he was jacked in that
[ __ ] movie oh yeah he was [ __ ]
just sweaty all the time but uh uh yeah
no i came here at 22's first time i was
just trying to think of that now yeah
the first time i ever came to america
period was when i was 22. hmm
yeah
the longest time scammed in the street
did you
oh they saw you coming from nova scotia
a mile away let's get this ac
this guy with his headphones
they uh hiya fellas i got uh man as as
many tourists in this [ __ ] city do i
got i got dinged with
comedy club tickets
dominating absolutely dominated me and
the guy i was with okay we were in this
competition in canada for comedy comedy
competition not dance
not rocky impersonations
you won this competition they flew you
to new york you got to perform at gotham
and they gave you tickets to see uh
sarah silverman at carnegie hall and i
think dennis leary at carnegie hall i
think it was i think it was for new york
comedy fest at the time that's [ __ ]
like make a wish for open mikers make a
wish for canadian open mic man
you want to look like a star was it was
the competition televised no it was
right it was on the radio but we so we
had to get up at 6 00 a.m
on the radio you did a radio competition
cafe dude the first time you came to
america you came as a contest winner i
lost oh god dude i lost here's my buddy
got a companion he took me with him yes
why because here's the thing i knew i
thought i was gonna listen let's make a
pact now if either one of us wins
no that's exactly what dude i used to be
pretty when i was younger i was like uh
i'm i got this i know what i'm doing so
i took the time off of work
absolutely
anticipating that i would win i lost and
this guy the guy who won he was another
comedian that i knew and he was like hey
man uh my my boyfriend can't go
do you want to come i go yeah already
got the time off work so then me and
this man he's like uh at the time he's
like a 40 something year old six foot
five giant [ __ ] man yeah walking
around the streets just yelling at
people and [ __ ] i had to kind of like
stand behind me because i was like man
this guy's just like he's losing his
mind and everything but anyways i got
screwed in
in times square dude the confidence hold
on the confidence to take off the time
because you've entered a radio contest
and you're going to new york and you're
assuming you're going to win the trip
yep is
all time crazy damn winning a trip well
here's the thing
yeah had i have won
and i what am i gonna i can't call in
sick then what am i gonna do i don't
know and also i did it with other
competitions i used to win some
competitions that's all there was at the
time you weren't going back to work if
you would have won that that was it
you're coming here
new york city i won five grand what ones
the job what was what jobs started one
that you called out of starbucks you
were stronger oh yeah for a long time
okay real quick let me tell this ticket
story they got coffee up in canada
yeah well you're making your website
you're making an old boot on an open
flame
and the [ __ ] wild tundra you stare
with a hockey stick now what after your
your friend dies from uh what malaria
not malaria
scurvy pirates there's another one
what's the other like
uh tuberculosis was big back then too
dysentery that was the one i was looking
for sure no wonder you lost that
competition
all right punchline something something
something somebody give me an occupation
so what are we doing right now
all of this is happening in canada
nonetheless
there's like nine people we got a couple
of real hoosiers on the line here hang
on
do a comedy competition gotta work hard
for them punchlines you know put down
your snow shovels you heard the the i uh
so i
i when i came down here okay i forgot
all of this was happening in canada
well i was this was in toronto but i i
i'm originally from nova scotia i moved
to whatever
so when i came down got him on his heels
none of this
he's flustered he doesn't know what to
do
we're having a good time yeah of course
i take back the classiness
radio the
radio contest but that's for the
occupation i get that we've done a lot
of shitty stuff in common you got to do
what you got to do wait you also said
you won five thousand dollars yeah at
another competition yeah what comedy
yeah are you guys paying attention i
don't know what's going on over here yes
comedy competition i was trying i was
only how did you take off work for that
you were saying that i should have quit
for the other thing when i won the five
grand a guy said to me because you're
going to quit your job right i go your
[ __ ] mind it's fine i'm not quitting
my job for five grand yeah that's pretty
clear after tax before taxes dude that's
trash yeah yeah yeah that's that's a
level of that's smart yeah that yes
that's smart it's trash to be like i won
5k pre-tax
i quit a job that i didn't even have
anything going on but i said i was going
out on tour with my band
just to quit the job did you have a band
no
have you ever walked out of a job uh
yeah i walked out of that one yeah but
you had a story you ever just straight
up
okay and i was like hey man they were
giving us like you know ten dollars an
hour or something but we weren't allowed
to take tips and then someone hit us
with tipsy hoffa
[Laughter]
i love the irishman i'll fight anybody
yes you want to run from a knife charge
again
charge a gun run from a knife oh my son
my ice cream no no because they gave us
i got a tip and we would take them or
whatever like if you were trying to
you'd have to deny it if they saw you
taking a tip but every now and then
somebody like oh here's five bucks oh
thanks and one of us got called it was
mean to a buddy i thought you meant like
a tip like they tipped you off they were
coming to rough years up no no no one of
us got caught
roughing up valets yeah right [ __ ]
games
the scabs scabs are standing outside
waiting to park cars yeah we're not guys
willing to hit this man with a pipe to
park a jetta what are you [ __ ]
punching guys in red jackets fighting in
the middle
like the end of anchor man
so a guy could
[Laughter]
that escalated quickly
no and we were like hey just let us you
know i'd rather you pay me two dollars
like take give me like the tip wage what
was this when were you i was in college
and it was my two real bozo buddies uh
that was like their career they had not
gone to college and they were like oh
we're gonna you know they were working
at this car dealership and they were
valets at the car dealership it was like
their job at the time and i was like yo
just give us like the 250 an hour and
let us take a dollar from every [ __ ]
car parking like 100 cars a day or
whatever
make a little bit of cash you know yeah
and then they were like no then we're
like well give us 15 an hour so they
said no and i'm like well then we're
going to walk out and then we walked out
my i was like well i'm going back to
school in a month anyway my two buddies
were like [ __ ] i gotta i don't have a
job now you started a revolution and
went back to dorm scene yeah and my to
do my one buddy shout out to ryan who
listens he had to dress up he had to
dress up for we're gonna make him pay
for this oh my cafeteria oh the meal
plan activated again
i see you guys a fourth meal i gotta go
stuff my book bag with chicken
sandwiches for my dorm kip let's talk
about bespoke posts bespoke post and
that box of awesome that they got
cooking over there
absolutely fantastic now it's the fall
yeah they got all cool stuff for the
fall new category do some outdoor stuff
you could do some home bar stuff even
grooming stuff it closed too
unbelievable that's right they're doing
close get some nice threads oh man you
gotta check out the box of awesome from
bespoke post yeah uh to get started just
take the box of all just take the quiz
at box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box for you
like we said a bunch of times it's cool
guy [ __ ] it's [ __ ] where you're out of
your buddy's house or you're at a game
or something you're tailgating he's
cooking someone rolls up with a cool hat
i called you where'd you get that box of
awesome baby that's what we're doing
bespoke post uh they sent us a bunch of
stuff you know i it's so cool i have
like this leather buck knife this buck
knife with like a leather thing i use it
to open all my boxes i feel like
crocodile dundee or something flash it
on the subway uh they've released new
boxes and then that's a knife uh they
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories it's free to
sign up you skip a month at any time or
cancel each box only costs 45 bucks and
has over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
you're losing money i don't know how
that math works out but you're losing
money
um so you get 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the code garbage at
checkout one more time write it down get
a pen pull out your phone that's box of
awesome dot com promo code garbage for
20 off your first box
kippy mint mobile mint mobile mint
mobile mint mobile mint mobile i'll say
it one more time for you mint mobile you
gotta check it out all right talk about
passing savings on to you
oh my goodness 15 bucks a month yeah and
you might be sitting there thinking
what's the catch there ain't no catching
this ain't one of the big guys no one of
the guys looking to rip you off no not
one of those big wireless providers
small towns boutique operations for the
people by the people yeah mint mobile
baby um they cut out the retail stores
so there's no need to sell uh you know
they don't have the brick and mortar the
guy standing there trying to get you to
[ __ ] sign a 15-year contract that
ain't the case keep the overhead low to
pass the savings on
to you no mystery fees or nothing at the
end of the month mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month all
plans come with unlimited talk text
high-speed data delivered right on the
nation's 5g wireless i've said it a
thousand times my wife uses mint mobile
it's fantastic she got it when she was
coming here back and forth and now she's
like there's no reason to sign up with a
big company right would you so if your
contract's up you're in the market
you're looking for a second number mint
mobile's the [ __ ] way to go if you're
not 100 satisfied mobile has you covered
with their seven day money back
guaranteed switch to mint mobile and get
premium wireless serving starting just
15 bucks a month and get your new
wireless plan
uh shipped to your door for free go to
mint mobile.com garbage that's mint
mobile.com garbage cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month mint
mobile.com
garbage do it my buddy had to dress up
like he was cause he was still living at
home so he would dress up and leave for
work in the morning because his mom was
there and he couldn't tell her he quit
so he would dress up and then like go
like henry hill exactly like henry hill
to park cars to park cars yeah all the
way back to uh another [ __ ] uh
scorsese movie 100 you never walked out
of a job i've walked out of four jobs
one job
my anxiety wouldn't let me do that i've
quit
have i quit i've been fired mostly yeah
he's a big fire guy i walk out man well
grocery store
uh restaurant
uh uh
what was the name of the restaurant oh
man guys look
do you want to keep making fun of canada
because here we go this place is called
boston pizza
they only have these in canada right of
course because there's nothing there's
nothing about it's not even known for
pizza look we know that they know that
they whatever man is not a chain or one
place it's a chain wonder if canadians
go to boston thinking they're gonna get
good pizza they don't probably compare
they're probably good pizza in boston
yeah but it's not known for it
all right it was like boston lobsters no
canada it is they uh where else uh uh uh
a best buy basically and a call center
was jobs i walked out they were all
shitty jobs that's their trash guy call
centers i've done walked out of that you
walked up a call center yeah how great
is that feeling it's pretty good the day
you leave that were you in like a little
cubicle sure was dude the day you pushed
back feds were closing in we had to get
out of there oh that's hilarious this
place was going to be open for a while
but i bailed i had to i had to [ __ ]
and the guy at the end did you have to
do an exiting interview no i've never
had to do one of those i think of one of
my jobs like one of my like
law firm jobs i have i thought you said
you just walked out walking thank you
as i was there the whole day i kept i
just was just [ __ ] around i was just
hanging up on people i was taking calls
and telling people i was at home with my
wife you knew you were leaving oh my god
what was the call center for next tell
remember next
so you were customer service for nextel
yes and nobody called in for a good time
everybody called in the last
call to tell you guys were doing a great
job nobody not one person was like if i
could suck you guys i would everybody
was like oh [ __ ] it one woman called up
one time she goes if you don't fix my
[ __ ] bill i'm gonna drive into
traffic and i
just put it on hold i was like holy
[ __ ] that's where she started driving in
traffic we don't gotta fix your bill so
i hung up a whole bunch of times the
last guy i talked to i just erased his
bill i was like i'm out of here i gave
this guy 700 bucks bailed as i had the
power to do that yes just to [ __ ]
delete a bill the power i had was this
dude i could check
anybody's
uh next tell phones and plans
one day a guy this is how long ago was
one guy a guy comes over to me goes do
you want to see how many phones dog the
bounty hunter has why i go yeah
so i walk around this thing and he goes
look all of these signed to dog this is
like nine [ __ ] next telephone
you're chasing when you got to get off
the ice
tough to get off that i just need a lot
of chirps chirp shorty chirp back
[ __ ] but i when i walked out the guy
goes hey he goes people walk out here
all the time so he goes would you do an
exiting interview and i was like of
course i will but then as i when i say
i'll tell you how bad you suck
that's exactly what it was the guy goes
he goes why are you leaving i go dude
this place sucks and i watch this guy
right down this place sucks then he's
like what would make you come back down
this place sucks
and then he goes what would make you
come back here i go dude if you guys
bulldoze this building and build a
mcdonald's he goes
the guy literally i would maybe stop by
if i had to go to the bathroom you're a
young kid at this time 19. i'll give a
[ __ ]
is this post uh contest winner oh pre
pre my dad had just [ __ ] rustled up
some uh some texas cruises
i just got off a horse
my the guy puts the pen down he goes
come on man i go write it down and i
watch this guy go bulldoze this building
build a mcdonald's and i walk down
that's pretty good walking out of a job
is one day right i feel like they're
gonna follow me i'm like i gotta make it
like two or three blocks so i go okay
i'm out my anxiety would get to me too
much you know what this guy's making a
lot of sense [ __ ] you guys exactly
that's what i was gonna say to foley do
the bit it would be fantastic but
ultimate knock [ __ ] over two camera
falls the [ __ ]
the speakers go all [ __ ] we shoot the
rest of it blair witch style
i'm crying into the camera i don't know
i can't do it
he's here a minute ago
we find little sticks in his the shape
of him
little headphone sticks
i'm in the corner
[Laughter]
waiting the whole story of blood
that's great
the 700 so you knew you were leaving so
you were like [ __ ] it did you clear
anybody else's did you no just that guy
just that guy because he he called he
was so [ __ ] like everybody's been
hollering
and this is that this is at the time
remember when phone every phone bill was
like 700 bucks if you called anybody at
any time you were [ __ ] this guy called
me and he was like almost in tears and
he was like dude i can't pay this bill i
don't know what to do i i go dude you're
good i go it's gone i i took care of it
he freaked the [ __ ] out he was like man
you got to give me your number this is
amazing thank you i go honestly it's my
last day you're lucky as [ __ ]
i'm out yeah and then there's a chance
that you're out there that nate oh i
would love
where is this i would love to know what
happened to this man you saved 700
he he could have he could be a governor
for [ __ ] if you had a next time he
could have his own providence what year
was it
that would have been like 2 000
five four
thousand four two thousand five what
about because you don't forget that oh
no whether you became a billionaire
you're not going to forget the time that
somebody took 700 off the next listen if
this guy needed 700 taking off his bill
back then he's probably not around right
now let's be honest i could have spent a
young kid starting out i say i say
opposite i say this guy's now a [ __ ]
scholar i say that's seven hundred
dollars
that seven hundred dollars turned his
life around switched it all it's like
it's like um it's probably six months
rent up there
he was calling from america oh the call
center was in canada al you were you
were outsourced scab get them out of
here wow you know what we had to say
because i'm from halifax nova scotia and
they would say just say if anybody
really asks because people were pissed
that the call center was in canada sure
yes why
because that people taking our jobs
they're [ __ ] taking our so they would
say that on the phone ah you're up there
and candid thinking oh gabs robin is
blind with your 700 phone bill they
would say if somebody asks you where you
are say the northeast and then they said
if they push it farther say halifax
because there's a halifax in virginia
uh
but also i'm from halifax north korea
they'll be like you're not lying but you
know wow but nobody ever asked me i like
how canadians are such good people
yeah technically you're not lying
if they push you harder tell them
everything they wanted meanwhile the
call center i worked at we had to
vaguely act like a cop and i'm not even
lying it was uh donations for the police
commissioners something yeah
you were a call center you were taking
donations he was doing pump and
dumpsters i've talked about this a
couple of times
when like you caught when you know like
the fraternal order of police
i'll take it
i got two sandwiches here
yeah i got i super sized it
uh yeah it was the fraternal order of
police type thing and you call it's like
fundraisers for cops cops aren't allowed
to call and say hey we're having a
fundraiser because you'll feel
obligated or threatened to give them the
money okay so you call which is exactly
what he's doing
no
hey i'm calling here from like the
commissioner's off whatever we were but
intimidation and guilt were your two
main powers no we would say don't you
want to keep the streets safe yeah
you have the sirens on a low hub in the
back
hold on wait wait wait a second we're
getting a call right now
uh but we had to change our name to like
scanner in the back we would change our
name to something more presenters
rattling what do you mean like i would
be like instead of being like hey this
is kevin ryan you know calling for the
whatever i'd be like hey this is uh you
know this is uh o'malley from
and i'm calling o'malley yeah
sergeant o'malley o'malley reporting for
duties say
[Laughter]
i don't want a gun just give me a billy
club
i'm old school
i'll walk the beat getting a billy club
and a whistle i'll clean these
get my ass kicked
every day that's all i need
i never had sex with my wife once it was
a missionary
position i shake my kid's hands
such an o'malley
good night good night
i got the flattest feet on the north
side of philadelphia that don't stop me
from walking my beat
yeah we're orthopedic shoes sliding
yeah just shuffling
[Laughter]
one of those wind-up toys
officer o'malley o'malley here
reporting for duty i get sunburned in
the dark
my hair's so red you can't see it
never touched a dropper gin
those are tough looks you ever see that
when someone has a gin blossom on their
nose i didn't know what that was my
step-uncle somebody had one where the
first time i saw one i was like oh my
god you're talking like their nose all
right my nose is all blown up and i feel
like they're out of fashion now right
yeah they'll come back
get your gin blossom kendall jenner's
got one like no yeah i don't know i
don't feel like people drinking get them
yeah yeah like maybe they do i just
don't see it somebody somewhere is for
sure yeah yeah they're probably less but
when you see them it looks like it hurts
all the pores and stuff you could like
scoop it that's not good yeah uh yeah
that's funny that's funny
all right let's tell you guys
what happened with these tickets what
tickets i got screwed in times square oh
yeah i apologize also hold on so for the
listener if you're not aware there's uh
there's schemers scammers all over times
square trying to sell you tickets and
they just comedy shows and they lie
about the lineup some are legit and some
aren't mo yes but most of them will be
like hey you know jerry seinfeld will
ferrell jerry's not coming no eddie
murphy's there for jim carrey somebody
told somebody jim carrey one time yeah
they were like jim carrey's gonna be
there jim carrey hasn't done stand-up
since like 1983. no yeah joe nathan's
performing the name but they don't it's
trash they don't work which i respect
the scam i respect a good scam they
don't work for the company it's like a
third party thing and it's just you know
typically
not the most savory characters you're
buying the tickets this is the only
reason i brought it up because of this
podcast are you garbage these are
garbage this is garbage so i'm walking
down the street and somebody yells they
go hey man you want to see a show and i
go
well i already have tickets to something
i'm a contest winner i'm adjacent to a
contest winner i won 5 grand
i'm the companion to the real winner
give me four in case i meet some friends
see that guy 10 feet ahead of me that
guy won i'm with him
this guy goes he goes uh yeah man uh
who we got uh good show at the club
tonight i go hold on did you tell him
you were a comic as well i don't think
so i'm a comic as well but here's what
here's how i [ __ ] up because i'm an
idiot i mean i'm a goddamn 22 year old
little bumpkin nova scotor so he goes
who are some of your favorite comedians
i don't even want talking to this guy
really now that i think about it but
it's cause you're in new york they get
you you like stand up they're doing you
know what i mean of course psycho um
he's industry
this guy wearing sweat this guy's from
dirtbag inc he's got one puma one adidas
on yeah
the spider-man pants top is superman and
he's got the sign for stand-up tickets
like as soon as i leave he's going to go
back and take pictures with you
yeah charge for pictures but he goes uh
he's like who do you like i go i don't
know chris rock and he goes chris rock's
going to be there
oh man they saw you coming from new york
city where everything comes true i go i
go don't lie to me man i go that's the
only guy i really like tom cruise dude
no [ __ ] he's got to be there salma
hayek's [ __ ] at the top of the hill
i see you wearing a superman t-shirt you
like superman believe it or not he's
closing he's doing that's right he's
doing it takes his glasses off comes
back he's right in your face starts
playing a [ __ ] little mini display
with the theme
so i go come on man he goes yep i got a
[ __ ] so i bought tickets and i said to
my friend who had the tickets how much
do you remember
40 bucks like something insane too like
i got i got robbed i got like 15 years
ago too so a long time ago oh no yeah
you could buy a [ __ ] you could buy a
mule in canada for forty dollars like
two mules ride yourself to california
yeah he he so i told my friend we had
tickets to see uh i forget who it was
that night but i was like i'm gonna go
to this man i'm sorry he goes [ __ ] it
i'll scalp these tickets who cares so i
went and said that's pretty good i like
that move he did scalp the tickets make
a couple of bucks because they were
freebies anyway exactly so now he's all
he's all in he's up i'm down you scalped
silverman you paid 40 tickets that guy
then turns around sells the ticket that
he bought that he won yes for cash yes
oh you're the bozo i know i told you so
i went and sat at a club for hours by
myself do you know what club it was uh
yes okay he didn't go with you no was it
off from broadway yes okay so
is it the one i'm thinking of broadway
comedy club oh it wasn't that one oh was
it no uptown more uptown but the uh the
other one that's off of broadway uptown
it's up in the 70s
it's up there oh okay stay up new york
but this is years ago yeah yeah so
anyways i said they don't book me anyway
i think you're the guy that told me to
take it
so i sit in the club and not only is
chris rock not there there is no chris
wrote wait he didn't show no way nope
nope i left this somebody's gonna be
sitting at the bar eating a sandwich
that marshall's that's up there right
now that used to be a pizza place
fantastic pizza so check this out yeah
after i go
and they still don't book me after i go
to the show i sit there for hours also i
buy forty dollar tickets
drinks i bought a hot chocolate for 18
bucks like just [ __ ] stupid i walk
out to go to the pizza place
hot chocolate you're so canadian man i
don't know i'll take a hot cocoa please
do you have marshmallows can i have a
hot cocoa and a candy cane please
[ __ ] elf sitting in the front row
like i guess do you want marshmallow i
brought my own today sir
have a thank
for the cutting board
chop it up for the [ __ ]
bunny i don't really drink that much
anymore whatever so
um so i i leave that place i go to the
pizza place and i i ask the guy if you
have any halibut
what's the fresh catch today
i'm a cod man myself
oh nate i older big [ __ ] tub of whale
blubber
um you got a seal i
[Laughter]
i see people order hot chocolate places
and i'm like what the [ __ ] dude i don't
really drink that much anymore i think
we talked about the last time i was on
the podcast so i drank hard from 13 to
18. i hadn't already i've seen rum naked
past couple of years one rum nate i
don't drink that much i got a hot
chocolate you think you think i i know
i'm an idiot i paid 18 dollars i could
have gotten 90 [ __ ] hot chocolates
for the rest of time for eighteen
dollars
your dick sucks up for eighteen dollars
let's hope not and if you can don't do
it save the eighteen blow yourself
break don't listen to this man dick in
your mouth eighteen dollars that woman
that's no
that's not even a number that middle one
so i go to the pizza place that's just a
boob i order the pizza the guy turns
around and who do i see on the wall
chris rock with this pizza guy
oh there he is i ate pizza i walked
because i was scared of the train i
walked from 78th to 42nd in the rain
eating pizza got robbed so anyways the
only reason i bring those tickets up are
you garbage some of these people are
garbage watch yourself very true very
that's a [ __ ] talk about getting
fleeced in new york that's
listen folks when you're coming next
time you visit new york griffin don't do
the nathan mcintosh nope did you guys
fly in or did you did you take a bus
took a sled
no i thought we flew we flew yeah yeah
can't let's talk about the good people
over there my fitness pal love my
fitness i don't mean myfitnesspal yeah i
mean it's my fitness pal it's an app get
your life turned around yeah now as you
know i've been struggling with my weight
uh-huh all right i've recently kicked it
into high gear turning over a new leaf
turning over a new leaf and let me tell
you something that people at my fitness
pal want to help you and they can yeah
uh it's not a rigid diet plan instead it
learns what you know it takes your data
what you eat all this stuff and and
you know gives you the best plan for you
like we said your version of healthy is
different from my version of health sure
everybody's on a different plan a
different program
um and that's okay you know what i mean
it's not everybody needs to lose 500
pounds or whatever you know it's like if
you're just whatever you're trying to do
they tailor it for you seems like a shot
at me but no it's okay it's not a one
it's not a one one shot fits all that's
all i'm saying
um
with myfitnesspal you're not going it
alone you'll have access to guided daily
workout and meal plans written by
dietitian exercise scientists nice
scientists and exercises scientists on
the case look at that um like drago yeah
plus you can get support from other
members with the shared goals like say
you know if somebody's like hey i'm
trying to lose 15 pounds you're like hey
me too you guys can [ __ ] community a
little work together if you're like hey
i'm you know a bigger guy trying to lose
200 pounds you got other you got some of
them too you know what i really are a
pal yeah so uh myfitnesspal does way
more than just count calories get
support you need to meet your health
goals unlock the amazing things
myfitnesspal can do like we did start
your premium membership today go to
garbage.myfitnesspal.com
use promo code garbage get a one month
premium membership for free
that's
garbage.myfitnesspal
m-y-f-i-t-n-e-s-s-p-a-l
dot-com code garbage for free one month
premium membership today
garbage.myfitnesspal.com do it
butcherbox butcherbox butcherbox uncle
hankey's got a butcher box let me tell
you something yeah i don't need a copy
for this one nope cause these guys are
home run city yeah let me tell you
something when you get meat these days
you're not really sure where you're
getting it from okay you go to the
grocery store who knows the antibiotics
this staff the other thing butcher box
sends you top quality meat yeah
unbelievable are you talking free range
i'm talking free range grass-fed grass
finish which is big organic organic
wild-caught seafood wild-caught seafood
and more sockeye salmon
delicious love it
you guys you know they sent us i mean
i gotta i'm ready to start going into
business for myself they sent you so
much time i know it's pretty crazy
unbelievable uh every month butcherbox
will ship you a curated selection of
high-quality meats right to your home
like we said no antibiotics no hormones
contains each box contains eight to 14
pounds of meat depending on your box
type that's enough for 24 individual
meals that's crazy i got ground beef
coming out my [ __ ] oh it's fantastic
it's packed fresh fruit
shipped frozen for your convenience save
time money it's all easy peasy they take
all the thought out of it the meat all
has that deep red color well you know
you know it's quality good stuff yeah
it's good it's way better than anything
you're gonna get at a grocery 100 uh you
can customize your own box or go with
one of those either way you get exactly
what you want free shipping for the
continental us
we're american baby right now butcher
box is offering new members a 10 to 16
pound turkey free in their first box
what people are what is nuts these
people are bonkers i gotta re-sign up
this keeps going because there's gonna
be a cow outside my house yeah they're
handing out turkeys like frank lucas
look at this
butcherbox.com ayg to sign up
butcherbox.com ayg to receive a free
turkey in your first box now back to the
show that guy's still doing comedy
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he is yeah okay
fight because i i believe so yeah all
right i didn't want to make any
declarative statements but i believe so
yes um that's great
all right fantastic catching up oh my
god uh as you know guys when uh you join
the patreon we will read your garbage
question on air it's just the best way
to do it we get so many submissions via
email dms everything but yeah the the
patreons the homies as someone say
get uh get first crack at it um
this one's from mike uh
let's see this one's from
roman joe have you this is i've seen
this have you ever had have you ever
used anything other than a regulation
mailbox as a mailbox i've seen a two
liter cut on a pole what yeah wow
is that allowed no i mean no it's gotta
be sanctioned by that kind of soda
it matters
it was yellow so it was either it was
green so it was ginger ale or sprite or
seven up top it was ginger so i'm not
putting an irs letter in a [ __ ]
mountain dew bottle
yeah that's crazy that's not a certified
mail it could be club soda and what's
the big deal
a lot of return to sender
to be doing that right like you can't
you got to be it was more country yeah
that's like a dirt road where the it's
like you know road one is your story
yeah yeah you know what i mean no i've
never never in my life well you were
apartments too so you probably had like
the the
we jammed the bottle in the door to keep
it open when you went to run for
something you know when somebody
wouldn't give you keys you [ __ ] jam
in the driveway leave it and run real
quick i love propping a door open
that's always real trashy too because
when you're smoking especially like out
back of a club or something yeah and
you're like someone else comes out like
dad watch a rock pop it up wrap it up
don't move the wrong one
god forbid i walk halfway around the
building you know what i mean i always
thought that that's insane to me because
i always thought it was even trashy when
people would have the mailbox and then
have the mailbox from the whatever
newspaper they read that was big around
a little outside like yellow or whatever
i'm talking about oh it's for this just
the newspaper when you sign our first
subscription for the newspaper you'd get
a little mailbox that went on the side
like under it or whatever yeah there's
also two dog [ __ ] in there
oh yeah
it was always
i hated people that had the just to
teach them
they
hey foley stop living under the bridge
with your bag of dog [ __ ]
i gotta stop these readers any time
there was also like i remember there's
somebody my neighbor had it was a cowl
like a cow their mailbox was like
decorated like a cowl yeah like the farm
animal a cow
oh you were saying cow i know that means
wait what are you talking about what do
you mean what are you saying cow cow cow
cow cow okay i apologize i keep saying
cowell like battle like cowell
hold on hold on stop the show
kevin
well now i'm thinking about it too much
what kind of what animal does milk come
from
where does what come from a milk comes
from a cow milk
cow you guys bought from what cow you're
saying cow dude you're saying cowl
like vowel can i buy a cow then you say
it cow call
911
wait you say it cow did somebody spill
water on you
i eat it after a minute
of the apples
hey somebody do a hard reset
hippie hippies on the fritz
squeeze the volume button
i'm thinking about it too much now
the double butt the hard the hard reset
what nfl team plays in dallas cowboys
the who how i i'm thinking about it holy
[ __ ] this is crazy
uh yeah wait you say it cow
cow
cow yeah cow you're really hitting it
though cow
really coming in hard yeah i don't know
it's now i'm i'm analyzing it too much
i'm not gonna get a fresh running cow
man but anyway somebody made their
mailbox a cowl slash cowl i thought it
was a batman mailbox that's what i
that's exactly what i said from the
batman his eyes the thing is the cowl is
the thing you put over your head yeah oh
i didn't he wears a cowl yeah cal did
you know that yeah big nerd oh wow of
course
i don't know why they should call him
the cow crusader really i mean he's got
a cape too wait all right let me i'll
get out of here
i'm walking out of this dude you want me
to do an execute interview
why'd you leave the podcast can you tell
me that
they made me post headphones
what would make you come back
no headphones pull those turn but anyway
somebody turned their mailbox into a cow
yeah which i always thought was insane
did decker have a decorative mailbox
people want like something other than a
mailbox yeah it's crazy crazy yeah i
look i grew up in apartments it was just
a [ __ ] silver door
for life yeah did you ever have this did
you have the the slot no did you ever
have the uh mailbox outside of the
building
where like some because sometimes now
they're in like they'll be like in the
parking lot and they'll be like a big
i've had one of those yeah yeah they no
i never did no that's that from where
i'm from that's a pretty small town deal
as well
i feel like you know like a rural area
they have just a [ __ ] stack of
mailboxes over there yeah yeah oh yeah
okay yeah and everybody goes there to
get the mail yes yeah
yeah that's real rural [ __ ] yes yeah
yeah
yeah roar
this one's funny this is from brandon
uh can you ride a bike with no hands
[Laughter]
dude is that a personal quest like can
you personally it's so can you it's so
cool it's so garbage and only a certain
kind of kid could do that [ __ ] when you
were a kid i could you could have ride a
bike with no hands in the kitchen [ __ ]
no could you kill me all right really
dude i had to oh dude yeah i had no
hands texting all through chicago yeah
no hands no feet
i don't have a seat it's just a head
how's your head on the bike how are you
steering what with the hips baby yeah
you lean it's all really even when you
make a turn you don't use your [ __ ]
hands oh yeah how i lived on a bicycle
for like nine years in chicago okay i
worked on a bike he doesn't have a
license i was gonna say i lived i was
like i don't need more of this story but
okay
no i never could do that i fell off no i
i no i fell off bikes yeah i crash bikes
i can bike but i mean i also
do you ever have one of those bikes that
folded in half
oh absolutely not because if you do
we're not friends anymore nathan are you
kidding me a friend of mine had a friend
of mine had one wait are you a kid yeah
i'm a kid i was a kid i i was a kid my
friend of mine had one of those that i
went to accountants who want to keep
their heart rate the [ __ ] sucker thing
opened that's happened on my leg and i
[ __ ]
ate it i just i ate it what it folded up
on you fold it on my leg like a murphy
bed yes
he's in the bike
dude that's
yeah it was brutal that's a businessman
trying not to pay the [ __ ] tunnel or
the bridgestone that's oh my goodness
i'll be home tonight honey the guy's
just biking through that poor kid how
did he have that bike his family got him
that bike i don't know we got him one of
those [ __ ] folding bikes but either
way long story short i never ever biked
without my hands not one goddamn time
never i do it now like when we'll go
down the shore ride bikes and i feel
it's trashy because i feel like i'm
showing off when i ride with no hands
i'm like look at this like i hope
somebody catches a good look at me can i
tell you something i'm always hoping
those guys will [ __ ] wreck sure of
course you're right rightfully so yeah
but when i was a kid it would be an
older kid tight body 10 speed tight
behind yeah like somebody was like
jacked when he was like 15. were you
killing people
tight body
just zipping down he was the guy that
didn't wear a shirt that's smart i keep
my shirt on just for the record
when i do it i'm sure i got there's
always somebody really cool that did
that when i was a kid yeah um i never
even not everybody could do that no i
for real i found it yeah it's crazy
you're you're an athletic boy now you
could probably do it now your center of
gravity is [ __ ] top-notch really yeah
get me a bike
turn the bikes
so we were yelling at moon towers to the
bikes because we ran those motorized
bikes oh yeah yeah yeah those things are
sweet they're good that's good good time
the fold-up bike
the toughest of all looks
man that's crazy walking to the office
your [ __ ] suit pants tucked into your
sock like a [ __ ] gig yeah you're in a
business suit with a school bag on it's
a bad luck i remember there was a i saw
a news story there's a guy that lives in
jersey that kayaks to the city
to save money oh my god
i'm hoping that guy drowns
i hope an oil tanker just [ __ ] takes
that dick out holy you're canoeing
across the hudson really
come on man one of those two one of
those big tankers
i'm sure he's beating them off with a
snake that guy
well actually
[Laughter]
you're trying to trying to wedge the
canoe in the elevator to go up to you
are we still on for happy hour later
that's real bozeman you can also do that
like back to the future uh move where he
hangs onto the ferry oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
power loves playing i was going to say
that there you go all right this one's
from liam i've never done this but is it
garbage to ask a stripper for change
yes yeah 180 times out of 180 times yes
you cannot ask a stripper for change
strip clubs already are international
waters whatever money leaves your your
[ __ ] pockets or no it's not your
money anymore sure yeah even if it's
even if you pull it out to count it's
gone that's that's up for the grass
that's up for grabs gone yeah you cannot
ask a stripper for change i would be way
too intimidated oh
i'm always scared they're gonna get to
bounce her throw me out some anything
it'd be one thing i guess if you was
like uh if she was okay if you got a lap
dance and you let's just set let's just
say i could maybe see that then to be
like hey do you have a 10 but whatever
give it to him but especially if they're
dancing on if they're on the stage and
you throw a five you can't be like throw
me back do ones
you can't do no lap dance either dude
i'm not i'm saying it'd be more
understandable first of all you know the
woman does not have like most of the
time stripper goes back there with you
she doesn't have the money where's she
keeping it she's got this they got this
much they got the crown royal guy
typically
where are you gonna okay at least the
places i i freaked out i was gonna say
i've never seen a stripper holding money
oh no they typically have a bag they
typically have a crown royal bag canada
don't do this but also we don't throw
money really on the on they don't think
of their overalls
[Laughter]
come out in full fur
hey you got mud on me
what the hell lady
clean your boots before you come into
the champagne room
full of fisherman's [ __ ] gear you got
a south western those big boots up your
waist it's not the champagne root it's
the milk jug room
get in here in the jungle come here the
bag of milk room canada's premier strip
club the car heartthrob
that's hilarious the riverbed
give it up for tonight's dancer gladys
no
these women are gorgeous and they're
naked
yeah can these ship clubs are like top
shelf right we don't we're not throwing
money on the stage all i'm saying so
when you go into the back with uh a
woman for a lap dance they don't have
they don't have [ __ ] they're not sure
your money on our show so anyways if you
go do you have oh even if they had money
on them if you said you have change
a bouncer should absolutely come in grab
you by your [ __ ] and throw you right
out of the goddamn window you're
flipping a looney at her
i can't do that in alberta then flip a
looney at them
i got thrown out of a strip club one
time
because we were sitting there and like a
couple strippers like waffles you said
it was all you could eat
[Laughter]
brings a tray of shrimp to a staple
this guy had a whole jar of maraschino
cherries get him out of here
we don't do that down here at the
riverbed
no we were sitting there and like a
couple like really kind of walking
towards us and i just and they like
looked at me and i looked over and i
just went like i went like that like you
waved to a stream like johnson
we got datsun over here
jesus christ you're a goober i did i
waved like that
and she got pissed because she thought i
went like hey
get away from me oh wow so then the
bouncer comes over and he's like is
there a problem uh you know the girl and
she was like get this [ __ ] loser out
of here dude [ __ ] pick me up threw me
out i was just [ __ ] how big was he i
was tripping my face off that's why he's
all goofed up on molly a massive yeah
those strip club bouncers are another
breed of yeah like another size of human
it literally is international
no they're not up for there's no
negotiation yes if you're like hey no it
was this you're everybody's gone yeah
some other bouncers you might maybe talk
to strip club bouncers or not those
people they'll throw you right through
the [ __ ] hole yeah yeah you're done
so don't ask for something i don't like
when you bring drugs in there either so
i've heard
[Laughter]
don't ask for change no yeah no you
can't do it you can't do it
uh that's crazy
you're paying for the experience i'm i'm
pretty
i'm pretty good with that
i love the throwhand experience please
of the i'm a huge dirtball experience
no
things like that i never worry about
like spending too much money because
it's like it is what it is you know what
i mean sure you can't nickel and dime in
those things no of course i mean look
man a woman has a goddamn [ __ ] in your
face you can't ask
change i i hey i agree i don't even like
asking like a waiter for chan i'm just
like hey if it's an extra seven bucks
you're getting that like whatever yeah
and if your tickets are on your head
also don't ask for change of course of
course of course thank you for your
service you might as well go farther
like what if i get a prostitute do i ask
for no yeah no no no that's a cat yeah
that's uh whatever you got on you you're
you're getting for sure yeah and no
checks everything's all a cart yeah can
i write you a chair take traveler's
tracks
um
what's your crypto wallet you're using
can i give you this nft
uh all right this one's funny this is
from chef teff uh did you drink diet
soda as a child
because if you did your parents weren't
great yeah if you you were on you were
taking some form of an idiot
adhd medication if you were drinking
diet cut well you can't have sugar yeah
it's not a three liter of diet cola you
weren't a cola fam growing up right we
were no but no
i would [ __ ] it maybe and i mean
maybe if i was out playing with the boys
and i came in and i had to [ __ ] go to
the garage and there was no soda or
snapple or juice or whatever and i had
to drink a [ __ ] diet coke i would do
it to quench my thirst
but that broad's gonna hear about it
when she gets home from work i can tell
you that right [ __ ] now that's gonna
be a problem that mom the second she
walks through the door oh now crystal
light on the other hand she walks
straight in she's like you believe these
[ __ ] guys asking for change while
you're stripping on top of them
you got a bigger problem lady diet
[ __ ] coke in the fridge the [ __ ] is
that well that's not gonna
[Laughter]
she's working the day shift
somebody's gotta she wouldn't be my mom
be working friday saturday nights
prime time and she has
she's got the goods i love you paddy
uh patty foley patty foley crystal light
crystal light diet all day fine boom
boom boom diet iced tea short diet soda
oh come on i love it now what are we
doing big fan hooked on this oh yeah of
course now forget about it yeah it's
working for you too
club soda diet soda's good as a kid get
elf except
there's a time where i would dabble in
diet root beer that ain't too bad what
was that time what was going on here my
dad when my dad was like when my dad was
like making a push to like lose weight
or
you know something he couldn't have
caffeine or something like that anymore
he was drinking a lot of diet root beer
i i i i would drink it with them
diet root beer together
so it's a real fond memory you have here
two coal miners saddling up at the bar
two diet root beers please he asked me
yeah i know but the way you paint it sit
there and drink it with them like you
just stare at each other yeah and drink
diet root beer together shake each
other's hands walk away
mom and work again yeah it's friday see
you back here tomorrow night
prime time huh prime time patty they
call it
10 to 4 a.m
10. she ain't getting until after
midnight yeah she doesn't do the
champagne room either all right now
oh that's [ __ ] great uh this was a
big one for me which was always
thoroughly embarrassing
um have you ever put plastic shopping
bag over your socks and your shoes to
keep your feet dry in the winter
yeah that was my yeah we were doing it
with zip locks
grocery bags over just shoes period
really raining i had these suede shoes
and i put bags over the whole deal
recently no okay where were you going i
was in
quebec city walking from somewhere to
somewhere i don't remember where you
took them off when you got into the
place yeah okay yeah i wasn't standing
at the bar with plastic bags on his
shoes
i think it was from a strip club telling
the church
back to the hotel
and uh i thought you went to bags or
from a strip club
no somebody's been a bar
i don't remember but i do remember
putting on yeah
i get that i'll give you that yeah
that's it but that's all will i do that
now no i would just look ahead and be
like i can't wear these today yeah yeah
yeah that makes sense of course but as a
kid especially when you're like going
playing in the snow it was plastic bags
with like either tied or like a rubber
band on it or something so your socks
wouldn't get wet yeah that's a regular
thing no we had snow boots
so did we
but i guess if like whatever it was you
know they didn't do the job all the time
they got [ __ ] up
you see the laces man everything comes
through that [ __ ] yeah he'd stay out
he's from canada i know you stay out
there until you got wet and then you go
inside yeah but that's what i'm saying
the shoes the the bags by another hour
yeah chicago stayed out you guys stayed
out
yeah because it's just it is what it is
it's [ __ ] crazy you know yeah we'd
stay out man you're just soaked i can't
do that well my mom showed me that she's
like put a plastic back my mind [ __ ]
blew i was like jesus christ you've been
holding out on me this whole [ __ ]
time what else are you telling what else
do you know
show me the tricks please
show me how to garbage man all right
let's do a couple more and then we'll
wrap her up here
this one's i never even thought about
this from jordan uh ever go to a car
dealership with no intent on buying
anything
i guess you're just looking for the free
coffee and donuts maybe
you got a lot of time on your hands my
parents went they went to bruce to
peruse there might have been a purchase
coming down the pike five six months
later taking some time
they're in the market though this man is
saying yes have you never even been in
the market and you show up i remember
being in a lot of car dealerships and we
never got a car that year oh geez well
you're in the market though people wait
years to buy things maybe this guy's
saying no market you just pull up to a
lexus dealership and walk in yeah and go
what's going on in here what are you
guys doing
and i would say no i personally have
never done this no no no that's great
with grocery bags on my feet or without
i would never
i no but i guess you can wait you said
they give you coffee
go get coffee donuts hey i'm looking i'm
not so you just i guess i don't know man
it's not something i would do but i get
people do it for sure let me ask you
this did you ever drive around with your
family and look at other houses no
apartments my whole life but just no
just to drive or not you know like just
to look at how not to buy a house you're
talking about just drive through a
neighborhood look at it yes i guess
sometimes for like what what christmas
christmas lights and halloween sometimes
because people do have their [ __ ]
houses pretty crazy yeah that makes
sense so that's we used to just do that
a lot for no reason jason the joint
looks like they're going to be on
vacation next week
they got a lot of diet cokes in there
the fat bandits
they only took the snacks
i left all the jewelry they left all the
diet coke
i only took the good stuff
all the crystal light's gone the fat
bandage oh that's great uh
all right this one i've we've i've
talked about a good amount and i know
you you've done it um this is from
michael haven't had a question right yet
ever throw his shirt straight in the
dryer for five minutes to make it good
enough to wear again [ __ ] yeah the
shirt's dirty
the fluff up we would say fluff it up
throw a little bit the trick is you take
like a wet sock or a wet rag throw that
in there and the moisture like steams it
what's the what's what what if the
shirt's dirty and you're jammed up and
you're going to where his class comes in
because he's a sharp guy yeah you're
very you're not going to get any of that
you're going to connect so listen when
you don't have a shirt to wear or you
want to wear a specific shirt to a thing
and it's dirty so you put it in the
dryer with a dirty one no it's a no with
like a clean sock you get a clean sock a
clean a wet in a plastic bag
and ask for change diet coke uh
and you throw it in there and turn it on
and it all the heat and the water like
creates like a
steam effect and gives it some more life
so yeah steam refreshing again
freshens it up a little bit this would
be another one of those apartment deals
i'm not spending a dollar fifty to put
one [ __ ] shirt that's true if you
have your if you got your own washer and
dryer in your house you can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want you can put anything
in there oh so you've never had your own
washer and dryer probably now in my in
my own unit
no wow oh
[ __ ] yeah no holy hell no that'd be a
laundry day did you have to do your long
laundry when you were a kid
no your mom did it when i was like a kid
kid yeah what age did you start because
i was like 13 my mom's about 13. yeah
she threw away talk about it and i put a
[ __ ] eggs put a jean jacket in the
goddamn uh uh washer
uh with the dryer well i did both but i
mean first of all it ruined everything
it ruined all the other clothes
everything was blue and then
yeah yeah yeah and in the dryer all the
buttons and [ __ ]
i thought it was gonna blow the goddamn
place up everybody's taking cover
holy so no i get look so i don't know
anything about this world that's all i'm
saying one shirt one shirt in the dryer
for a dollar for you don't do that in an
apartment yeah you're not doing that in
a park what do you do now do you drop it
off and pick it up or do you do yourself
i never drop it i don't think i like
doing laundry you do your laundry i do
get anything dry cleaned
sometimes like a suit shirts do you iron
anything i got a steamer you do yeah
that shirt's fresh
i guess yeah sure yeah is it yeah yeah
it looks really sharp it's iron that's
what it was sharp yeah okay wait thanks
guys you're a sharp dress which reminds
me before we let you out of here mm-hmm
we have a couple of questions that have
kind of been
brewing lately since you've been here
that we'd like to feel you out a little
bit
please no on the podcast yeah great yeah
please do you brush your teeth in the
shower no
never right for not one time
milk with dinner uh probably happened at
some point in time but yeah like okay
dude did you ever kind of just ask did
you ever brush your teeth in the shower
that seems like an 80s movie i just
started doing it like [ __ ] uh you
know
michael keaton has to sure fix it it's
like a montage yeah yeah yeah yeah a lot
of people do it in the shower i have
yeah
i have i have
i'll admit it right here but do i do i
as like a no god jesus christ i do every
day here's the hot button here's the hot
button you're poor wife i know you don't
yeah i do every day i mean yeah
sometimes sometimes i'll just do it in
the shower
because you're pissing into an open tub
that you're not even bathing the one
thing is like there's no anything yeah i
give it a squirt with the hose that's
not soap that's that's he squirts
himself you're not getting needed you
just added that
you added that part when we pushed you
you don't put any soap i don't buy a new
tub every time bath fitters
1 800 bath bitters they come in three on
top defenders hey his tub is this
[ __ ] high they they don't even take
the old one otherwise it keeps getting
smaller and smaller just a sink now it's
just a toilet like cups
no i i don't i don't brush my teeth in
the shower listen here's a hot button
issue that's tearing this country apart
right now
you're getting dressed
what's the order you're a naked man out
of the shower boxers okay
shirt
pants
socks
i knew you were a gentleman first
uh before well no i'm so gonna
wear a sock shirt
underwear socks but here's the thing
when i go shower i just take underwear
and a shirt with me i put those on and
there and then i come out and do
everything else what i i crazy i think
that's why i do it too because i used to
do that too i don't do it anymore i live
with my lady i can walk in the [ __ ]
house with my goddamn you know what i
mean i don't got to worry about i'm
going to bring all my [ __ ] in there no
i'm sorry the fact that you bring
anything in there oh i'm not coming out
straight no i don't like i don't like
just walking i don't like where my i
don't wear headphones correctly you
think i'm coming out of the back this
guy's a little kooky with a towel
wrapped around me what am i [ __ ] wait
but leonardo dicaprio is it isn't
everything all steamy in the bathroom
you're putting on like i take cold
showers
man
this guy keeps all the time
yeah yeah for the last few months yeah
yeah since the last time i was here the
last time i was here i felt i was a
little too garbage so i was like how can
i change some things yeah this guy's not
hot water cold shower not like freezing
cold shower not like the guy in the
[ __ ] kayak to work
but yeah no yeah yeah i take cold
showers so there is no steam that's one
of the perks of taking a colder shower
there's no goddamn steam but aren't you
still kind of wet your skin when you put
those underwear i dry off fully yeah i'm
a little wet when i still this guy rolls
out of the tower he doesn't even grab
listen i don't care how good you are
with the towel you need about five
minutes to let the air really dry your
skin i think that's so you need about
nine guys with squeegees yeah
that's a you thing i feel like yeah
that's i understand your personal life
is not your business
i mean the royal us
he doesn't know what that means i don't
know what that means yeah i think it
means everybody yeah and i've been using
it sure and lately to look smart i've
been telling people my favorite actors
uh laurie metcalf
okay it's pretty sharp it's good yeah i
know that you know what's funny i i'll
i'll i'll i'll i'll go with you here i
know that name i couldn't picture that
person right yeah couldn't picture it
but if we were to feel bad about that
of course
holy [ __ ] yes sister she's on screen too
yeah great yep great but if we were at a
party you'd be like oh yeah oh yeah yeah
when it's everybody say yes somebody you
kind of heard of you're like oh they
know what they're talking about it's
really denzel
but yeah i go i go boxers shirts that's
that's right i come out of the bathroom
figure the rest of it out yeah i
understand that question when does the
deodorant get applied after i put on the
shirt yeah you always go after shirt
otherwise it gets on it yeah you'll
always go after you have to yeah you
make that mistake one time i do it naked
i thought you're gonna say i don't know
what do you do t-bone after shirt yeah
yeah otherwise why would you go under
and stretch your shirt out you stretch
your shirt [ __ ] is going on with these
guys could you do it because if you put
yourself you guys all canadian if you
put your shirt on it gets on your
[ __ ] shirt i don't use antiperspirant
like a weirdo you use the white stuff no
but it's still like it still gets
residue gets on there what are you
talking about man yeah plus once you put
the shirt on it gets a little deodorant
on the shirt yeah which i like makes a
little more fragrant on a shirt yeah a
little bit of a little bit of a barrier
hmm oh smell me yeah moisturizer what do
you do do you go are you straight you
start at socks you go up i'll tell you
my whole
that's to get in the shower
i got my shower shoes on i get out of
the shower
i get out of the shower i dry off i open
the door i let all the steam out i go
out i let the cold there take a hot
shower
i feel i'm looking at you baked
you could cook salmon in your shell
just all in tin foil the only thing the
only thing you're missing is the old bag
garlic bread's
oh i love that ready bread at the
grocery store but yours is hot as [ __ ]
like a hot shot i'm a hot chocolate yeah
yeah i get out i get outside i either
stand in front of the fan
all right fans going in your house 24
hours a day regardless of what season it
is a little bit okay yeah we got that
going off stay in front of the fan let
everything or i'll flap the towel
coldest day of the year fans blow into
this man's house yeah then i go back in
i use a hair dryer to go back in
i gotta go back just when i think i'm
like numb yeah i'm going back my second
tour in a bathroom today i go back
things got a little messy the first one
i got some unfinished business i have to
take care of fortunate sun's blaring
i see a red door and i
helicopter noises
i go back in i use my hair dryer to dry
my hair and my nether regions i like
everything nice and dry
all right then i apply my gold bond
spray cream which i've talked
[Laughter]
do they still make that or you have
stuff left over from like 94. no it's
[ __ ] spray wow okay okay
so i use my spray on asbestos
really seal it up
a ball uh just a hair dryer on your bald
business hundred percent wow is that not
cooking yet is that not good it's hot
it's hot it's sizzling
around is it doing this
never gonna be able to have kids that's
too hot though you think okay you're
nuking them you're literally microwaving
your bag every day yeah twice not good i
get it all fresh put my fan before too
fan on the balls and then the [ __ ]
pure hot flames you're nuts i have to do
this this is the maintenance i got to do
[ __ ] deodorant and then i go out and
i'll put a dirty shirt on i'll put i'll
put my socks on because i usually don't
go naked i'm naked
okay i'm naked in the house okay all the
time i'm naked poor sofa oh
poor poor sofa
man
okay so socks sorry you start so you're
absolutely naked dried off now you start
with socks start with socks and then
pants
okay but if i had underwear lobsters you
don't do boxers i usually don't do
underwear are you kidding me but if i do
it's boxers and i yeah i'll go boxers on
underwear why don't you do underwear i
don't know i just don't like it is this
not garbage is this not one of the best
there's a lot of me there's a lot of
things
we've had to just accept when it comes
to him and his hygiene we're labeling
that garbage good all i'm saying is
we're labeling no underwear unless
you're at [ __ ] burning man sure it's
garbage garbage for sure right for sure
yeah but that's like every day of your
life no underwear if you've got a ranch
hand
no he's got ranch on his hands
right now i'm wearing cargo pants good
great it's fantastic you have underwear
no right right now i don't i can smell
you're doing a show tonight we're doing
a big show we're getting a man reelected
and you're showing up [ __ ] swinging
in the wind with a thin veil yeah wow
now if i'm wearing shorts i'll put
underwear on thank god yes
or sweatpants because sometimes they can
be a little too revealing especially
those thin ones so how many pe you just
don't do boxers or anything nothing
interesting okay so you got your pants
on
that's a fit thing though
if the if you had i can i i i know
you're you had them that fit you would
wear them
no because i do have a pair that fit
sometimes that's what you're saying you
have all pair that it's a fat thing yes
that's what i'm saying it's a fifth
thing you just like you had a pair of
underwear that fits no no i have pairs
that fit
are there no underwear for big for
bigger men there are it's just he's
closing comfortable his clothing thing
is bananas he's been wearing this shirt
every day for i'm not even joking three
months
and he just keeps making excuses
you know it took me seven minutes to
leave my house i'm not [ __ ] around
because the shirt i wanted to wear this
is so stupid i mean i go i wore this the
last time i was on this show sure so i
put it back this guy's been wearing this
on this for weeks months
i guess
whatever dude
underwear for big people they do it just
doesn't buy you
i don't like the way it feels against my
body
tight that's what it is no it's not i'm
telling you it's not that i'm a naked
kid were you one of those kids you
kicked the diaper off you ran around all
the time because when you were not this
fat you wore underwear yeah yeah so i
was telling him for a while i slept i
slept winnie the pooh style i would
sleep with just a t-shirt and nothing on
my bottom exact t-shirt
dick wrapped up in it
i couldn't sleep naked at all
way too vulnerable yeah no especially
with my lady i feel like she's peeking
at me i gotta be chubby
what are you doing jeans in a winter
jacket
when you take off your clothes do you
say sorry
i'm sure i got a toque winter boots yeah
that's what someone asks hold on this is
another question
a tuque is a is a beanie it's a winter
night yeah winter they call it two
winter hats yeah
oh yeah and i only dropped that
reference solely because we're making
the canada joke sure we call them
stocking hats get a stocking you're
stocking that on yeah it sounds like
you're about to knock it over exactly
yes yeah about the crack is safe exactly
one mom was a real good second floor man
yeah we gotta wrap it up all right
listen gang we love you namak we love
you to death uh anything that coming up
you want to follow any shows twitter
instagram uh twitter and instagram
nathan mcintosh uh podcast positive
anger i got some albums on itunes and
also i'll be doing shows at uh dr grins
check it out in grand rapids in december
and i'm also doing a new year's eve show
in saint paul on new year's eve and new
year's day
uh yeah you check my website for these
as well nathamactouch.com i forgot about
positive anger i apologize it's a
fantastic uh podcast you gotta let's do
it and i'm telling you right now we say
this a lot on this show this man is one
of the funniest guys could possibly see
live if you have a chance to see him go
see nathan mcintosh we love you kippy
you got anything for him i kevin ryan
comment on all social media uh get the
tickets for
uh new york like we said come see us in
the city and then upstate new york and
connecticut will be get those tickets to
the funny bones yes sir we love you guys
and we'll see you next week